well the lucky little  let's try it again the lucky little  wedding chapel voted best of las vegas  is marrying people like crazy today one  of a number of places offering pop-up  chapels to satisfy the high demand it's  also on track to be a record-setting  month according to owners rachel and  henry snead  our really really big day is 222 2022  which may exceed 10 10 20 20. we did  over 100 weddings that day so i think we  have about 80 already booked  international travel is back you know  and  with this being the lunar new year just  i think yesterday you know we have a lot  of asians coming as well and we love  that again you know because of our name  lucky and they choose our chapel  the lucky little wedding chapel can  completely outfit its patrons it's got  flowers gowns tuxes you name it they've  got it